on est avec nous bien médias bien sûr et
couleur capillaire
c'est magnifique à votre merci j'aime
beaucoup je contemplais bien entouré
merci à côté c'est une nouvelle à sa
perle audrey je ne connais pas son nom
de famille parce qu'elle n'a pas voulu
me le donne et non ses secrets ses
secrets et ses miss audrey c'est miss
audrey hoenheim merci des plats alors
rôderait eux ce n'est pas moi qui l'a
recruté c'est la production ils sont
beaucoup sur son instinct moi je ne suis
pas sûr un stade mais au moins on a
parlé et ils ont dit qu'elles étaient
venus dans la grosse rigolade
un jour donc elle est drôle et léger ce
malien va aussi vous sûr je commence
quand même métier pourquoi moi et je
suis mais je suis mannequin défile et
voilà c'est tout
elle est magnifique et battez vous savez
quoi lundi je propose que ouais ça non
mais c'est vrai que maxime jean pascal
passe exactement les mêmes parties